[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to the
Mobile Ads Garage.
Today is all about Firebase,
Google's mobile platform that
helps you quickly develop
high quality apps,
grow your user base,
and earn money.
If you watch the
keynote from I/O 16,
you heard that
Firebase now offers
a whole bunch of new services
and that AdMob is one of them.
So in this episode, with the
help of Gary the Graphics Guy,
we're going to cover how
Firebase and AdMob work
together, what the benefits
are, and then we'll
have screencasts showing how to
import the Mobile Ads SDK along
with the Firebase SDK.
But first, let me
step into my app
so I can welcome our
first ever guest star,
noted Firebase expert and star
of the Firecast series, David
East.
[FANFARE]
DAVID EAST: What's
up, everybody?
ANDREW BROGDON: What?
We have company.
Now then, David, maybe
you could tell our viewers
about what Firebase is.
DAVID EAST: Sure.
Yeah.
Firebase is a unified app
platform for Android, iOS,
and web development with
tools to help develop faster,
improve app quality, acquire
and engage users, and monetize
apps.
ANDREW BROGDON: So what kind
of tools are we talking about?
DAVID EAST: Man,
there's a bunch,
like my favorite, the real-time
database, notifications,
crash reporting, analytics,
and, of course, probably
your favorite, AdMob.
ANDREW BROGDON: So part
of the platform is AdMob?
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
Firebase is designed
to help developers
at every stage of the lifecycle.
So you can actually get a
lot out of the Firebase tools
at no charge like analytics,
remote config, push
notifications, and then AdMob
will actually go and pay you.
No.
It is true.
I'm actually not that
good of a salesman.
ANDREW BROGDON: Firebase
and AdMob are friends, Gary.
OK.
So that's why someone
would want to use Firebase.
But what about how?
If an AdMob publisher wants
to get on board with Firebase,
how do they do that?
DAVID EAST: Well,
they can actually
link AdMob apps to
Firebase projects
right from the AdMob website.
And then, mainly, it's a matter
of getting the config file
and importing the SDKs.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cool.
So around here, I
like to list the steps
before we do a screencast.
So let's break it
down for Android.
So to get an Android
app up and running
with AdMob and
Firebase, you just
need to link the app
with a Firebase project,
download the
Firebase config file
and include it, configure the
Google services Gradle plugin,
and then add
individual services.
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
I can't see anything.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Gary, unblock him.
David's a nice guy.
Haven't you seen Firecast?
What's the problem?
Is that what this is about?
It's still you and me buddy.
AdMob's not going anywhere.
You don't have to use Firebase
with it if you don't want to.
The API isn't changing.
The SDK still works
the way it always has.
If publishers don't have to
make big changes, neither do we.
Absolutely.
We can still catch a
ball game together.
DAVID EAST: Yeah.
I have season tickets.
See?
It's a win-win.
ANDREW BROGDON: Now
that that's settled,
let's get to our
screencast and take a look
at how to use Firebase and AdMob
together in an Android app.
So here are the four
steps for Android.
We're going to begin
with the first,
linking an AdMob app
to a Firebase project.
I'll include a guide at
the end of this video
with more info on how
this linking works,
but for now, one of the
easiest ways to get started
is just to go to the
Analytics tab in AdMob console
and click this nice Get
Started With Firebase button.
When I click that, I get
to a list of my AdMob apps.
And I can click the
Link to Firebase button
to link one to Firebase.
That gets me a prompt
for my app's package
name, which is needed for
the configuration stuff
to work later.
And depending on
whether you've already
created a Firebase
project or not,
you may have some choices
on the next screen.
This is what you get if you've
never created a Firebase base
project before.
Clicking continue will take
you to the next screen--
one that looks like
this telling you
that you now have a linked app.
And so that's step one.
Step two is to download the
google-services.json config
file, which is really easy
because the screen I just
showed you has a link
to it right there.
Just click that link.
And you'll be sent to
the Firebase console.
And the download will
start automatically.
Once it's downloaded, I can go
into an Android Studio project
and drag it right into the
source tree, like that.
It goes in the root
folder of the app source.
And it'll be used later by
the Google services plug-in.
Cool.
So step one and two down.
On to step three, configuring
the Gradle plugin.
So here, I'm back
in Android Studio.
And I'm looking at the project
level build.gradle file.
That's the one that applies
not just to the app,
but everything in the
project's source tree.
And so I'm just going to
add a little class path here
for the Google services
plug-in, which is new.
And we're doing a Gradle sync.
There we go.
With that done, I can head
into the apps build.gradle
and add a line at the
bottom to apply that plugin.
There we go.
This plugin uses the
google-services.json file
to inject configuration data
into the app when it builds.
And it also does
some other Firebase-y
set up kind of stuff.
So that's the plugin.
Now, it's time
for the last step,
adding individual services.
I can do that the same
way I always have,
through Gradle dependencies.
So for AdMob with Firebase,
the Gradle artifact
is called firebase-ads.
There we go.
There are, by the way, a ton
of these artifacts available.
Here's a list of the services
along with Gradle dependencies
that go with them, which you
can find in the Firebase Android
Setup Guide.
And you see there's a
bunch in here-- real time
database, authentication,
everything you might want.
So that's all four
steps finished,
which means I can come back
into my activity file now
and start messing around with
AdMob classes, like AdView.
And you can see, the
type is resolving.
So you know the SDK has
been properly imported.
So what did you think?
DAVID EAST: Looks
all right to me.
ANDREW BROGDON: Excellent.
So up next is iOS.
Let's take a look
at the steps there.
Gary, hello.
And we're back to the
pudgy redhead jokes.
All is right with the world.
David, do you mind?
DAVID EAST: Nope.
To get an iOS up and running
with AdMob and Firebase,
first, you link the app
to a Firebase project.
Then you download a
configuration plist file.
Next, you update your pod file
to reference the Firebase pods.
And then initialize
Firebase in your app.
Thanks.
I'll let you do the
screencast though.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
So here are the
four steps for iOS.
And we're going to
begin with the first,
linking an AdMob app
to a Firebase project.
There's a bunch of ways
to get started on this.
And I'll include a guide
at the end of this video.
But for now, I'm just going
to go to the Analytics tab
in the AdMob console, where
the front-end team has
this nice, Get Started
With Firebase button.
When I click that, I get
a list of my AdMob apps.
And I can click Link to
Firebase, right here,
to link my app.
That gets me a prompt
for my app's bundle
ID, which is needed for
the configuration stuff
to work later.
And depending on
whether you've already
created a Firebase
project or not,
you may have some choices
on the next screen.
Here, you can
either link the app
to one of your existing
Firebase projects
or create a brand new one.
Either way, once you're
done with this screen,
you get one that looks like this
telling you the app is linked.
So that's step one.
Step two is to download
the plist file that
contains your
Firebase configuration
information, which is crazy
easy because the screen
I just showed you has
a link right to it.
Right there.
That'll take you to
the Firebase console
and start the download
automatically.
Cool.
So that's steps one and two.
Let's take a look at
step three, updating
the project's CocoaPods.
So I'll head into Xcode.
And here's my very
basic iOS app.
And I'm going to use CocoaPods
to get the Firebase SDK
and the Mobile Ads SDK into it.
So the first thing I need to
do, actually, is close Xcode
and create a pod
file using pod init.
There we go.
So I got a pod file, which
I'm going to edit using Vim
so everybody out there
thinks I'm smart.
Cool.
Inside the pod file, I just
need to add two dependencies
to my target.
First is the Firebase
pod, which gives me
access to basic Firebase
stuff, like the Firebase app
class, which you'll see
in a second, plus Firebase
Analytics.
And then a second pod for AdMob.
There are, by the way,
a ton of these pods.
Here's a list of the
available Firebase services
and the pods that
go with them, which
you can find in the
setup guide I'll
actually link you to later.
But as you can see,
there's a whole bunch.
Cool.
So now, I do a pod install to
get all my new dependencies.
There we go.
And now, I'll open
the workspace file
that CocoaPods made for
me to get back into Xcode.
So that's steps
one through three.
The last step is to
initialize Firebase.
To start, I'm going to
grab that plist file
that we downloaded earlier.
And I'm going to drag it into
the root of my source tree.
Firebase uses this config file
to store a bunch of keys and ID
kind of things.
That's what the file's for.
There we go.
Next, in my
AppDelegate I'm going
to import the Firebase framework
provided to me by the pods
and then call the configure
method in the Firebase app
class.
There we go.
That configures my app
at launch and makes
sure that all the
installed Firebase
components are ready to go.
So that's it.
I'm done with all four steps.
And AdMob with Firebase
is ready to go.
That means I can come into the
view controller, for example,
import the Firebase
framework, and start
playing with AdMob classes.
Here's a GADBannerView.
And you can see the type
resolving, right there.
So you know the SDK has
properly been imported.
One thing I do want to
note is that the dedicated
Google Mobile Ads SDK, CocoaPod,
the one that everybody's
been used to using
up until now--
that has not been deprecated.
So if you're not interested
in using Firebase,
but you do still
want to use AdMob,
that's an option for you.
It's not going away.
Also, if you don't
want to use CocoaPods,
you can also download
these frameworks directly
from the Firebase developer
site, firebase.google.com.
So that's iOS.
I'm going to put up some
resource links for you guys.
But first, thanks to
David for stopping by.
DAVID EAST: My pleasure.
By the way, if you want to
learn more about Firebase,
you can check out Firecast,
where we cover everything
you need to know about Firebase
for Android, iOS, and web
with step-by-step screencast.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sounds great.
Thanks.
DAVID EAST: Thanks
for having me.
So that's one good resource.
You might also be interested
in the AdMob quick starts
for Android and iOS, which we've
updated to include Firebase.
We've also updated
our AdMob samples
to show the use of Firebase.
So you can check
those out on Github.
And we've got a
help center article
that covers how
to link your AdMob
apps with Firebase projects.
And the Firebase support page
has a number of good options
if you have questions.
As always, if you have technical
questions about the Mobile Ads
SDK, stop by our support forum.
And Gary and I will
see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]